grab your wine and your popcorn we're
celebrating hollywood's big movie
milestones welcome to entertainment
tonight everybody when we begin with the
big one a disney classic and it's
turning 30. michelle i'm gonna say oh
boy tale as old as time song as old as
ryan i could keep going i know she would
it is beauty and the beast
both a little scared
not a one prepared beauty and the beast
i think that i did it really
just for the fun of it and because i
thought my grandchildren would enjoy it
isn't that stupid
angela lansbury brought the iconic mrs
potts to life and the star behind the
voice of belle paige o'hara
[Music]
every day
like the one before
what is the line of your characters that
you get requested or sent back to you
the most oh gosh without a doubt gaston
you're positively prime evil gaston you
are positively primeval
only e.t got paige richard white who
played gaston and robbie benson the
voice of the beast back together for a
reunion robbie i don't know if you've
heard this before but lawrence fishburne
val kilmer and mandy patinkin all
considered for role of beast but you
beat them out there was a
long line of people who auditioned for
the part but uh yeah i guess i got lucky
belle
[Music]
are you
happy here with me no
are you happy here with me
[Music]
who is beautiful as me this was going to
last for the ages and and i i felt that
very strongly at the time
and 30 years later it was thrilling
hearing paige bring belle back to life
there's something sweet and almost kind
but he was mean and he was coarse and
unrefined
now he's dear
and so unsure
i wonder why i didn't see it there
before
now let's get to a coming-of-age film
that celebrated the purest kind of love
the one between two best friends in my
girl
i only surround myself with people who i
find intellectually stimulating he's
kind of a shy kid you know he always
needs someone else to stand up for him i
ride bikes she's pretty intelligent i
like that she's a hypochondriac and
i don't like that how are you feeling
as good as can be expected hard to
believe my girl turns 30 tomorrow
in 1991 e.t was on set with then
ten-year-olds macaulay culkin and anna
klumsky all right matt
yeah
my girl marked the first feature role
for anna they played best friends
navigating life and young love one
two two and a half
three
at the time home alone had recently hit
theaters propelling mac into super
stardom home alone is the number one
grossing comedy did you hear that yeah
yeah you know
i have that calculator in my hand you
know
yeah you could say culkin was a bit
precocious behind the scenes we saw him
calling the shots action
dad somebody's here
okay
the film also co-starred dan aykroyd and
jamie lee curtis who told us working
with kids got expensive from the first
day i said to them okay look at i swear
a lot but i'll pay you ten dollars for
every time i say the f word and five
dollars for every time i say the s word
and
i've lost a lot of money already
no no excuse me 100 i didn't say it in
front of him of course macaulay culkin
all he wants is vanilla ice tape and
he's happy
he's happy with the vanilla ice tape
okay well here's a sweet fact the kiss
between macaulay and anna's character
won the very first ever mtv movie award
back in 1992. now you know that my girl
actually opened the same exact month as
this tv classic hit the big screen the
addams family
it's like very much like a family kind
of atmosphere except that they are very
weird don't torture yourself gomez
that's my job she's flirtatious and
she's suspicious and
she's devoted to her husband she has
these two rather ghoulish but but
adorable children morticia and gomez
adam's two ghoulish kids were son
pugsley and daughter wednesday who were
played by jimmy workman and a then
ten-year-old christina ricci
don't be a baby
i know what i'm doing
she's
a no emotion little girl she doesn't
show lots of happiness or she doesn't
show you when she's sad she'll crack a
little smile sometimes or she'll give
you a little evil grin but that's pretty
much it
some fun facts about this film john
franklin played cousin it and had to
wear a giant floor-length wig that
weighed 35 pounds
there was a three-hour segment where i
was inside it and it's about 120 degrees
and angelica's slinky black dress was so
tight she had to lie down flat in it
between takes
with time and and with the increasing
lack of lunch
i was able to maneuver a little better
and catherine zeta jones will be the
next morticia for a new netflix series
shooting in romania so excited to be to
be working with you know the great tim
burton and luis guzman playing gomez who
i worked with on traffic is going to be
really a wonderful kind of camaraderie
i'm really looking forward to doing it
[Music]
now from creepy and kooky monsters to
muggles and wizards harry potter and the
sorcerer's stone just turned 20. i'm
harry harry potter i've had a number of
people tell me that when they're really
really hungover and feeling in a very
bad place like that that they are like
comfort films for them so i think they
do occupy just like a very comfortable
place for people when we first met
daniel emma and rupert back in 2000 they
were just pre-teens on the brink of
stardom how do you feel about becoming
famous pretty cool
saw the billboard it's scary i could be
that big it's just scary i've got
millions of role models
brad pitt he's very good looking i
haven't seen any of his films but i'm
looking forward to flash forward two
decades and a multi-billion dollar
franchise later daniel made his broadway
debut naked rupert is dad to little
wednesday and emma became the princess
of our dreams plus she was rumored to be
dating her former co-star tom felton he
even went to see her in beauty and the
beast we actually have a group whatsapp
which i invited everyone
really from the main cast from harry
potter to come to
um the screenings and matt lewis and tom
felton came could you ever see the two
of them together yeah i could it was
always something you think so with the
spark you saw a lot
i don't want to start anything but did
anyone say like while you guys were
filming no not really but you saw some
sparks there was some sparks
come with me
and you'll be
you know timothy chalamet sparked our
imaginations when he gave us all a sneak
peek at his take on willy wonka but his
caption says it all the suspense is
terrible he's gonna go this time i hope
it'll last
well the suspense is gonna last until
2023 that's when this prequel featuring
a younger wonka is expected to hit
theaters until then we'll just enjoy the
original which turned 50 this year
charlie bucket
i'm baruch assault
i'm my tv
augusta's clue julie you and denise both
had a little crush on peter during
filming is this true we've taken in
turns to who was going to stand next to
him michael what do you remember most
about that famous scene falling into the
river and the tube
that they stopped the water at the right
time otherwise i would have been drowned
okay paris gene wilder called you and i
quote at one point a little brat and a
handful you know that i i love you now
you were a troublemaker then i was
spirited
is that a good word for it sadly gene
wilder passed away in 2016 and denise
nickerson who played violet passed in
2019 but notably while most of the cast
has kept on acting charlie is the only
role peter ever had these days he's a
veterinarian
i just didn't feel that you know being
an actor was where i wanted my life to
end up you know